-Welcome back
to "The Tonight Show"!
I'm here with our very own
Tariq Trotter
from The Roots right there.
Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we are going to play
"Virtual Reality Pictionary."
Here we go.
-♪ Virtual Reality Pictionary ♪
-But we're gonna need
more players,
so joining my team
is the Emmy-winning star
of "The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel."
Please welcome Rachel Brosnahan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, buddy.
Come on.
That's my partner right there.
Joining Tariq's team,
his new album,
"Come Home The Kids Miss You"
is out now,
please welcome the one and only
Jack Harlow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, we're -- we're
playing against each other,
but we're still friends.
-For now.
-Yeah, for now.
-Yeah.
-Try and get in your head.
-The game works
exactly like "Pictionary,"
except the person who is drawing
will be wearing one of these
virtual-reality headsets
and drawing in 3-D space
using a program
called Tilt Brush.
We'll be able to see their
point of view on the big screen.
I will go first.
You guys can take your seats.
We're gonna do this, buddy.
We got this.
-All right, you got it.
-Thank you.
Okay, now,
what number should I go?
What do you think?
-4!
-2!
-All right.
Two people said 4.
All right.
[ Laughter ]
So, we're gonna go with 4.
-Enthusiastically.
-Yeah, they were like,
"4, I guess."
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-All right.
Wait. Hold on.
-You got this!
-We're off to a great start.
-All right.
I got this right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, ready to do this?
Here we go.
It's a thing.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
-A heart.
"I love you."
[ Laughter ]
A penis.
A cactus.
Uh, uh, uh...
Ed Sheeran.
-Ed Sheeran?!
[ Laughter ]
-A banana.
-Yeah, oh!
-Oh! Banana.
Banana split.
-Yes!
[ Dinging ]
-What?!
Yes!
Oh, my gosh!
That was awesome!
-This could've gone very badly.
-Wow!
All right.
Tariq, you're up now, bud.
Here you go.
-All right.
-All right, come on.
-It's pretty simple, dude.
[ Laughter ]
-What number, Jack?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Someone said 10.
Someone said 10.
I love that.
-Okay.
This is a place.
-Oh, God.
Draw with detail.
-It's a place.
All right, here we go.
He's going.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh...
-Jail.
[ Laughter ]
-Jail, he said!
That's awesome.
-A mushroom.
[ Laughter ]
Ah.
More detail.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Use the spa--
Explore the space, Tariq.
It's 3-D.
-Shut up.
[ Laughter ]
-The White House.
-No, no.
-Oh, I know what it is.
-Aw, gee.
-Don't tell.
-Oh, yeah, I can't say.
He keeps drawing the same thing.
-Yeah.
-Oh, oh, I know.
-Jack, you know what this is.
-Not yet I don't.
[ Laughter ]
-I think you do.
-Yeah, it's like a --
it's a destination.
It's far away.
-Mars.
-Jesus, not that far, Jack!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad tuba ]
-I think it's Stonehenge.
-It's Stonehenge, yeah.
-Stonehenge.
-There wasn't a lot of detail.
-Wrong generation.
-Here -- that was good.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-Oh, it's my turn.
-Here you go, pal.
-Mushroom!
[ Laughter ]
-Jail was the first one.
-Jail was the best one.
-3!
-I heard 3, I heard 3.
-9.
-No, I heard 3.
-I'm not looking.
-I love you!
-This is a thing.
-I love you, too.
Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
This is a thing.
Oh, God.
-Uh, is it --
-Wait.
-All right.
I'm sorry, I'm giving that,
and then this is here?
-Yeah.
-Does that feel right?
-Nothing feels right.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-Come on, bud.
We got this.
Now, what is it?
It's a thing?
-It's a thing.
-Thing is the worst subject.
-Yeah, yeah.
Okay, ready?
-Yep.
Ooh.
Ark.
Noah's Ark.
A boat.
-Oh, no.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, no.
Someone's drowning!
Someone fell off the boat.
-Uh-huh.
-"Help! Help me!"
-Yeah.
-Help!
Do something!
There's two people.
Oh, my gosh!
It's Jack!
It's the Titanic!
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
How are we getting this?
-This is --
What was that?
The -- The --
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
Look at that.
-Your turn.
-Titanic!
-That is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Banana split and Titanic.
-That was what
I'm talking about.
Titanic.
[ Cheering ]
Which one you going with?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Oh, boy.
-Go 5, go 5, go 5, go 5!
-5?
[ Audience shouting ]
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-It's a generational thing.
-You look bummed that you got 5.
-Right.
-You look bummed
that you picked 5.
-It's an activity.
-Okay.
-I might just do the activity.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's cheating.
-All right, which one's this?
That one's there, I believe.
And this one's here.
-So, which one draws?
-This one draws.
Oh, sorry.
-The right hand -- the trigger
on the right hand.
-This one draws.
-Yeah.
-I'm leaving you alone.
-I can use whatever I want?
-Oh, I would -- no.
-You want me to use the --
-Yeah, yeah.
That's good.
Yeah, don't --
-The timer start yet?
-No.
Yeah, now it'll start.
Go.
-Uh, here we go.
All right.
-Nice, nice.
-Uh...golf.
Golfing.
Uh...
Um, miniature golf.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
What are you talking about?!
What?!
He wants to bring it in.
-You know!
You know!
-Virtually bringing it in.
He's virtually bringing it in
right there.
Unbelievable.
All right, come on.
Jack, you did it already.
-That was amazing.
-Gosh, unbelievable.
Miniature golf...
Oh, my gosh.
All right.
Now, look, it is time
for the final round, okay?
And this is the showdown.
Rachel, you will draw.
-Okay.
-And then, we both --
both teams guess in this one.
Whatever team guesses first
wins 10,000 points and wins.
-I thought
you were gonna say $10,000.
-No.
No.
Definitely not.
[ Laughter ]
-We can take the lead
on this one.
-This one, you're gonna
go for the win.
-This is for it all.
[ Audience shouting ]
-2?
I heard 2.
-All right, I'm not looking,
not looking.
-Neither am I.
-I know.
-Uh...
[ Laughter ]
This -- This is a phrase.
-Phrase.
-Oh, no.
-Come on, bud.
We got this.
All right, wait.
Hold on.
Wait. Which one is it now?
I know, hold on, hold on.
I think it's like this.
-Okay.
-Sorry.
Let's pound it out.
[ Laughter ]
All right, here you go.
-We're so good at that.
-Yeah, we are really good
at that.
-Okay, ready?
-I'm always ready, yes.
-Oh, no.
-Come on, pardsies, we got this!
-Okay, okay.
-It's a phrase.
-Circle of friends.
[ Laughter ]
Circle of trust.
-Chicken.
-Chick, chicken --
-Quack.
Duck, Duck, Goose.
Uh, two --
-Two birds of a feather.
-Kill two birds with one stone!
-Migration.
[ Dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What in the world
is happening?!
Wow!
-How did you get that?
-Look at us!
Look at us!
-We won a game!
-Look at us, we won the game!
-All right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good game.
-Thank you. I appreciate it.
-Good game, good game.
-My thanks to Rachel Brosnahan!
How awesome was that?
Jack Harlow.
More with Rachel
after the break.
Stick around, everybody.